For this project, I’m going to show you
how to use the secrets of the Force to turn
a handful of gummy bears into custom Star
Wars gummies.
To start this project, you’ll need something
to mold your gummies, and I’m using these
Star Wars trays that my brother got me for
Christmas. You should be able to find them
online, or at one of the novelty stores at
your local shopping mall.
The trays are silicone and actually designed
for freezing ice cubes, but they work impressively
well for making chocolates, and gummy candies
as well.
Now all you need to start casting your clones,
is a big bag of gummy bears. So go ahead and
dump the entire bag on the counter, because
they’ll all need to be sorted out in just a second.
The cool thing about using gummy bears, is
that the candy is already made. So that means
you don’t have to worry about following
a recipe or messing around with food coloring,
and flavoring. Instead, all you need to do
is figure out a way to liquify them so you
can pour them into the molds.
Get busy separating all the colors into different
piles, and you’ll probably end up with mountains
of red, green, white, yellow, and orange,
which in this case all seem to be fairly even.
With the colors sorted out, it’s time to
grab a microwave safe container like a glass measuring cup.
Fill the container with as many, same color
gummy bears as you feel like, then simply
put it in the center of the microwave, and
nuke it for around 10-15 seconds. If it needs
a bit more than that, don’t go longer than
10 seconds at a time, because you’ll end
up making a really big mess on the inside.
The syrup is ready when all the gummy bears
have melted completely, and the gummy goo
is just runny enough that you can pour it.
Which is exactly what we’re going to do
next.
Slowly and carefully pour the molten gummy
goodness into the ice cube trays, and try
to resist the temptation to lick it, or pour
it in your mouth. It’s really hot and will
probably burn you, so be careful and use something
like a spatula to catch the drips instead.
These will need some time to cool, so while
we’re waiting, let’s go ahead and melt
down all the other gummy bears as well, and
fill up the rest of the molds the exact same way.
When the trays are filled, give the syrup
about half an hour to cool on the counter,
then carefully move them to the fridge so
they’ll firm up as much as possible.
They’re going to take about 5 hours to fully
set, but when they’re finished, go ahead
and pop the gummies out of the molds, and
take a good look at what you’ve created.
You can see there’s a fantastic amount of
detail that gets captured in the candies,
which is impressive considering how quick
and simple they are to make.
Now with more intricate molds, like the stormtrooper
helmets, it might take a bit of stretching
and prying to get the candies to come out,
but you’ll see that once they release, they
quickly spring back into shape.
Keep in mind that there’s really no limit
on how big you can make your candies either.
So let your imagination run wild with that
idea, and see how far it takes you.
Well now you know how to transform a bag of
gummy bears into a tasty batch of colorful
Star Wars gummies, that you could randomly
bust out at the next Cosplay party, or simply
use to bribe your kids.
By the way, if you don’t want to spend money
on big bags of gummy bears, there’s a much
cheaper option you can try instead. I used
Jell-O, gelatin, and a bit of corn syrup to
make mountains of colorful LEGO gummies that
look and taste just as good. Look for my recipe
on how to make these, in another project video.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
project perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com